how's it going browse in men name
[Applause]
[Music]
crows
welcome to the why everyone youtube's
favorite show back at it again another
week another week filled with wonderful
memes now obviously a lot has happened
as always we ended that subscribe to
peep I'm even I just want to say thanks
to everyone for being respectful about
that and understanding I think most of
all maybe there will be some old memes
slipping up it's done ok the thing is
done and we're moving on that's right
everyone so let's just jump into it I
drew pewdiepie and Marcia in Studio
Ghibli style oh my god
that is absolutely amazing that's
incredible
there it is everyone I'm so happy I saw
it live look at that beauty subscribe to
pupa now this is what I mean
some old memes are gonna slip up
obviously they worked on this for two
weeks the meme is still over ok but this
felt to me like a wrap of wrap-up of the
whole thing and they changed everything
on the website - thanks PewDiePie
instead I actually saw it live I don't
know if you guys saw it already there it
is that's it it was so hard to see and
then he disappeared out of nowhere yeah
oh my god I see it look at that the
batter didn't start too strong look at
that a nice wrap up to say the least
Thanks to everyone for donating and
organizing this I think it's so cool I
think it's a perfect example of the
positive things that people did but you
know we had phoned everyone let's just
move on me it does literally anything my
grandma incredible yeah
thanks grandma Diggs so I was scrolling
through random rooms and found this gem
Wow I have sure now that's being
creative in a good way
good job Petey pie nine-year old army
piston cup teeth
Thank You beautified thank you guys Hey
huge and March they have both
disappeared from social media three to
four days ago and the last couple of
videos are clearly pre-recorded based on
the tumble upload they're marrying
somewhere I'm telling you and it's been
exactly a year since the proposal well
played days and for noticing all these
things honestly impressive like how I
cannot hide anything from you guys too
bad you're wrong though we didn't get
married you dummy dumb schmuck cap um
remind me guys to never become a rapper
what is that he was supposed to be I
think I said that this in so many
moments it was mainly when people kept
doing the the challenges like at least
be somewhat decent at it and I'm not
good but at least I can make a song not
some completely cringe
I'm so proud of this community I'm nonny
let's show this to Felix in case he
thought that idubbbz was his friend what
the Frick
I do have frickin dare you kiss my
gertjie f just like that without her
consent shame on you
how Paul is Ian Jesus Christ no say it
ain't so no no hello it's me Darla
PewDiePie
I'm here to bring up the fact that I am
drinking my favorite drink of all time G
fuel and I'm saying that uh neurotically
even though it sounds sarcastic G fuel
enter the code PT pi and you get 10% off
G fuel try it out maybe you'll like it
there's a wide variety of flavors
hopefully I will get my own flavor one
day that would be a gift from the gods
but until then keep slurping my dudes
things that will end in 2019 Game of
Thrones Avengers Star Wars subscribe to
feedback this is so sad a
congratulations to your cooperation
guess if you want one minor boy you
needed that unbreaking we make a game
that allows users to be as creative as
that they want the game becomes very
successful the game gets overrun with
annoying kids driving a lot of people
away from the game the game gets overrun
by annoying kids driving a lot of people
have weapons the game it suddenly
becomes on ironically relevant in 2019
because all the annoying kids have moved
on to fourth i legit wanna play
minecraft again daughter did you do it
number one on Trini yes I think I know
where this is going and what did it cost
ending the subscribe to clarify me
everything this is so sad I'm shaking
and crying finally the day has come the
war is over
beating a music company with two songs
do you think YouTube's algorithm finally
Hey we made it on trending guys so happy
literally stayed up until 4:00 a.m. to
make this I hope you like it me review
hell yeah
hahaha PewDiePie uploaded 28th of April
and in the sub - PewDiePie me attention
New Yorkers will be flying on April 20
now the timing could not have been worse
I'm so sorry
it'd be neat if my promposal made it to
your propelled promposal o promposal I
know I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but I think you should care to
prom with me
well that's not your opinion so you
followed through ten out of ten that is
so sweet
have a great time and prom turning
eighteen becoming a double nine year old
double nine year old got this coca-cola
can since 2013 and I'm still watching
periods
that's pretty though thank you for still
watching this person try to unlock your
phone I'm gues Jamie I did at nine euros
I met Felix and my SIA they were so nice
I was too starstruck like a doofus so I
forgot to tell him that he has created
an amazing community and no matter how
the media portrays him we know that he's
a kind genuine person and I'm proud to
be part of this community that is so
sweet when Felix is held in the camera
we're in Marseilles holding the camera I
think I need to buy a better camera
these servers may have won more subs but
Pierce one more heart and that's a fact
that's right everyone Asian kids coming
home with a bee on their report please
no care we have stupid last week I asked
you nothing but this week I'm asking you
will you go to prom with me oh it didn't
work oh it's okay I've also been
rejected for prom it's okay and it's not
gonna hold against you your entire life
you'll be fine me when I accidentally
punch a wolf in Minecraft please don't
kill me I'm stupid I can't help it it
happens to the best of us oh my god
God - are you even out of phase where do
you pause at the right moment god damn
that's scary
what letter of the cat alphabet will I
get instead of e dr. Phil is turning 69
this year dr. Phil on your birthday meme
review it has to happen I don't care if
you strike all my videos
me view I know it's a review but what
that wise is read re pierce doesn't know
how to play his own game but he also
doesn't know how to sing his own song
veggie lasagna whichever with it
no those are the legs it's my song I
make up the rules manga anime Netflix
adaptation there it is everyone this is
by the king saya guy okay what do we got
yep doing a bunch of shuffling oh all
ages very epic okay yeah then why yeah
they should all still be there right
did I miss something yes what is he
doing okay Wow what now Oh hashtag thank
you
where am i right that's awesome thank
you
brofist question mark at a hundred
million meanwhile brofist to God thank
you guys for watching this video see you
tomorrow
check out merch link description three
more days and that's it what you never
played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]